[Music]
how can we trace humans from the great
apes small question well we are actually
a great ape species we're a human great
ape but we have four cousins the
nonhuman great apes
so gorillas orangutans z-- and then our
two closest living relatives chimpanzees
and bonobos
and so we share a closest we share an
evolutionary link with them as part of
the same family and so actually it's
only been around sort of five to seven
million years that we diverged from I
last the the last common ancestor of
ours diverged from chimpanzees and
bonobos so one of my interests is is
trying to understand what our last
common ancestor looked like through
studying our closest relatives
chimpanzees and bonobos and then humans
so when do we share with them and and
what differentiates us from them what do
we share with them or different Jace's I
mean a huge amount like in terms of in
terms of my area of interest I study
behavior really and we we share a huge
amount of our behavior and our cognition
with with other great apes in particular
chimps and bonobos they live in very
sort of complex social worlds like we do
and they deal with quite similar social
problems that we deal with so we see a
lot of overlap and they also have long
periods of development so like we do and
the offspring take a long time to grow
up which provides this big period of
learning and learning about the social
world so we find that actually a lot of
similarities but there's some obvious
differences tuned so I think some of the
major differences I would say
I said the similarities over outweigh
the differences but their differences
that probably major things in terms of
completion behavior would be our
capacity for language our capacity to
understand other's minds
so perspective-taking theory of mind and
our capacity to accumulate huge expanses
of culture and that might require
special skills like teaching and
imitation which we think seem to be
quite special in humans not necessarily
unique certainly special you focus a lot
on empathy and I was wondering whether
you could tell us a little bit more
about that yes I'm really interested in
empathy because I think it's the way
that we connect with others is is one of
kind of most profound experiences that
we have as well as that as an individual
and that encompasses an emotional
connection and a cognitive appreciation
of someone else's view and it seems
quite complex and so we want to
understand where that comes from and so
I think to understand that one way to
look at it is to look at what we see in
the closest relative of ours and what we
see in ourselves and what we find is
actually
we find a lot more similarities and I
think people had first realized and
interestingly grapes and the empathy we
see in great apes and humans also looks
rather similar to things we're seeing in
even small mammals like prairie voles or
or or Ravens for example so I think our
understanding of empathy it's it's
really becoming enriched by looking it
in nonhumans and try to understand the
process of empathy so I'm interested in
in how our animals feel about each other
do they have feelings do they care about
each other we think that they do and
what's the evolutionary basis for
feeling for others
and how cognitively complex is it and I
think you can do a lot actually without
being hugely cognitive about its empathy
seems to be really an ancient capacity
from which it's like we've got these
added layers but I think the base of it
is something much more ancient than I
think we've appreciated so how does
empathy actually manifest in yeah that's
a really good question I mean so I think
it depends on how you define it because
I mean some people would sort of define
it in that it really requires this
feeling for others so it requires not
just the experience of experiencing
someone else's emotions but it's it's an
outward emotional experience so your
feeling for them and you're typically
expressing that through doing something
that alleviates their distress for
example so you might help them or you
might provide them comfort so it's a
complex phenomena to study but one of
the ways we look at it is by looking at
how animals deal with distress in others
so if someone's wrote what I look at in
young and young Apes is if someone's
really upset does anyone come over to
them and pretty much give them a hug or
sit next to them stand by them show them
that kind of comfort and we find that
they do and we find that not just Apes
do it but Ravens do it elephants do it
even though some evidence that fish
might do it
so it's this it's looking at how they
respond to others experiences and we're
finding some really interesting some
effects across different taxa
I think might sounds fascinating well
what are the evolutionary explanations
for this behavior yeah it's a really
good question I think like well some
people have argued so a McLean and
arguing in the 80s that empathy might be
something thats related to mammalian
parental care
so when mammals evolved and then mothers
obviously lactated for their offspring
it created this need for responding to
others needs essentially and that you
know empathy as we see it might have
evolved from this parental care
mechanism that has then extended to
family groups because you do see empathy
like predictions of empathy is that you
see it in close social groups so the
closer you are to someone the more
likely you are to find to find their
distress upsetting but we now find
evidence for it in other taxes so we
find it for example in Birds we find it
potentially in things like fish not
necessarily in reptiles yet but I think
the idea of it I think the idea of it
being linked to mammals is now probably
unlikely but I think responding to
others needs is quite a strong there's
quite a strong evolutionary explanation
for that particular if there depend
on you so I think there can be genetic
benefits from responding to others needs
particularly if they've got like kin
relationships to you so it's quite clear
to me what the explanation would be if
it's about a mother offspring
relationship but in your research has
this has empathy been expressed with
between animals yeah yeah yeah yeah so
empathise are just limited I mean it's
it's more likely to occur among like
individuals that like have a close
genetic relationship we think but it
certainly can get expanded to
individuals that are close to your care
about so the other thing is we now know
in animals like friendship and social
closeness it really matters and like
having a social network and like having
a buffer of having friends around isn't
just something that special to humans is
something the animals need as well and
so like for example monkeys and macaques
and baboons who who have more friendship
networks and stronger friendship groups
they tend to have longer and they have
longer reproductive success and more
offspring like it's good to be social
therefore I think that like you
responding to others needs can ensure
that you've got this you know the
support network around you which kind of
pays for everyone but it you know has
this benefit to you if you've got a
buffer of social support it's one of the
reasons I think
nowadays we live in quite isolated ways
and actually primates show us and how
important is to have connections with
others and like how important it is for
your your fitness as a social species so
the selfish gene isn't that selfish in
the end well I think that the analogy
the sort of the metaphor is a little bit
incorrect in the sense that it it's
beneficial to one's own gene and sort of
survival if you can cooperate and work
with others and be prosocial to them
it's not incompatible with the idea of
empathy or altruism it just shows that
there's a yeah so I think being selfish
doesn't always pay in fact it might pay
to be more cooperative and nice that
doesn't mean it's bad or good it just
means that it it comes work as a
strategy yeah there's a crossover yeah
right well just talk about this in the
last debate but like I think there's
been this idea that animals are kind of
these selfish animals you know that they
surround dominance and self-promotion
but actually if you look at what most
animals do including humans they're
doing all these interesting cooperative
things and they're helping each other
and they're like you know sharing
empathy and we've want to understand why
they've evolved in animals and we're an
animal so that he was just a part of
that process of understanding I think is
there something that we as a species
should learn from other species and the
way they structure their societies and I
think in the connectedness of animal
social groups like as it as a social
species I think like one thing I think
of when I like because I've studied wild
grapes in the forest and and and so I
thought often thought to myself what is
it that they're doing that we could
learn from
I think being really engaging in the
present connectedness that you have with
others is really important and like the
power of touch these very simple
mechanisms of connecting you don't need
language to always connect there can be
a physical contact or a physical
closeness that could be really important
for people's underlying stress for
example and so I think animal like to me
I've learned like the importance of
fostering and encouraging social
connection as a social species we need
we need it to be successful it's not
just a kind of add-on it's essential I
think living in these individualized
societies that we have in the West can
result in these mental health problems
because I think connectedness is
something we can't really deny ourselves
and I I will just ask you to more
general question yeah sure
well one is more general and that is
there an idea that you recently changed
your mind on oh it's an idea that I
recently changed my mind on that's a
good question
all I need to think what I don't know
but this is I'm still like I've just
been in this debate about evolution and
whether or not we need to kind of we
whether or not it died away nearly
leisure and sufficient to explain all
the things and I mean I wouldn't I've
changed my mind I'm definitely thinking
about it and because I saw I already had
a view that like the way we approach
evolutionary theory is already doing a
pretty good job but I think maybe I want
to think about a little bit more
carefully about some of the ideas that
they were discussed in the debate so I'm
not saying I've changed my mind but I'm
open to expanding my mind I mean we've
got to expand our minds right so which
ideas and made you questions I think
that that sort of Darwinian evolutionary
theory or at least the kind of main
theory of evolution has sufficiently
explained all the things that we now are
seeing
in in behavior and genetics and so on so
and the particular examples and yeah
things like epigenetics and like the
kind of landscape of selection and
things like that
I'm trying to think of anything else has
changed my mind it's a good question
well there was a nice study about I just
not really changed my mind but there was
a really there is a cool study about
fish consciousness and fish that I did I
never really didn't doubt that fish
might have some kind of self-awareness
but there's a really cool paper showing
that fish recognize themselves and
mirrors and let a lot of people have
argued that this is something special
let them say apes can do humans can do
elephants can do like now fish can do
this it's like a fish can do this really
complex thing that we assumed was
special like you know we should kind of
really question what metrics were using
to study intelligence for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you